So now let's talk about the problem
a little bit more and specifically, let's
talk about the two different ways of
estimating parameters.
One is called maximum likelihood
estimate that I already just mentioned.
The other is Bayesian estimation.
So in Maximum likelihood estimation, we
define best as meaning the data likelihood
has reached the maximum, so
formally it's given by this expression
here.
Where we define the estimate as
arg max
of the probability of X given Theta.
And so arg max here just means it's
actually a function that would return
the argument that gives the function
maximum value as the value, so the
value of arg max is not the value of this
function, but rather the argument that
has made the function reach maximum.
So in this case the value of argmax is
Theta.
It's the Theta that makes the
probability of X given Theta reach its
maximum, so this estimate intuitively
also makes sense, and
it's often very useful, and it seeks
the parameters that best explain the
data.
But it has a problem when the data is
too small, because when the data points
are too small,
there are very few data points.
The sample is small,
then if we trust data entirely and try
to fit the data and then we will be
biased.
So in the case of text data, let's say
our observed 100 words did not contain
another word related to text mining,
then our maximum likelihood estimator
would give that word zero probability.
Because giving a non zero
probability would take away probability
mass from some observed words which
obviously is not optimal in terms of
maximizing the likelihood of the
observed data.
But this zero probability for all the
unseen words may not be reasonable
sometimes, especially if we want the
distribution to characterize the topic
of text mining.
So one way to address this problem is
actually to use Bayesian estimation,
where we actually would look at
both the data and all our prior
knowledge about the parameters.
We assume that we have some prior
belief about the parameters.
Now in this case, of course, so we are
not going to look at just the data, but
also look at the prior so the prior
here is defined by P of Theta.
And this means we will impose some
preference on certain Thetas over
others.
And by using Bayes rule that I have
shown here,
we can then combine the
likelihood function with the prior
to give us this
posterior
probability of the parameter.
Now a full explanation of Bayes Rule
and some of these things related to
Bayesian reasoning would be outside
the scope of this course, but I just
give a brief introduction because this
is a general knowledge that might be
useful for you, so the Bayes rule is
basically defined here.
And allows us to write down one
conditional probability of X given Y in
terms of the conditional probability of
Y given X.
And you can see the two probabilities
are two conditional probabilities are
different in the order of the two
variables, but often the rule is used
for making inferences of
a variable.
So let's take a look at it
again, we can assume that P of X
encodes our prior belief about the X.
That means before we observe any other
data, that's our belief about X, what
we believe some X values have higher
probability than others.
And this probability of X given Y is a
conditional probability, and this is
our posterior belief about X, because
this is our belief about X values after
we have observed Y.
Given that we have observed Y, now
what do we believe about X now, do we
believe
some values have high probabilities
than others?
Now, the two probabilities are related
through this can be regarded as the
probability of
the observed evidence Y
here given a particular X.
So you can think about X as our
hypothesis.
And we have some prior belief about
which hypothesis to choose and after we have
observed Y, we will update our belief
and this updating formula is based on
the combination of our prior here and
the likelihood of observing this Y if X
is indeed true.
So much for a detour about Bayes Rule.
So in our case, what we're interested
in is inferring the theta values so
we have a prior here.
That includes our prior knowledge about
the parameters.
And then we have the data likelihood
here that would tell us which parameter
value can explain the data well.
The posterior probability combines both
of them.
So it represents a compromise of the
two preferences.
And in such a case, we can maximize
this posterior probability to find a
theta that would maximize
this posterior probability.
And this estimator is called the Maximum
a Posteriori or MAP estimate.
And this estimate is a more
general estimate than the maximum
likelihood estimate.
Because once if we define our prior as a
noninformative prior meaning that it's
uniform over all the theta values,
no preference, then,
we basically would go back to the
maximum likelihood estimator because in
such a case it's mainly going to be
determined by this likelihood value
here.
The same as here.
OK, but if we have some informative
prior, some bias towards certain values,
then MAP estimate
can allow us to incorporate that,
but the problem here of course is how
to define the prior.
There's no free lunch, and if you want
to solve the problem with more
knowledge, we have to have that
knowledge and that knowledge ideally
should be reliable.
Otherwise your estimate may not
necessarily be more accurate than
maximum likelihood estimate.
Now let's look at the Bayesian
estimation in more detail.
OK, so I show the theta values as
just one dimension value and that's a
simplification of course.
So we're interested in which value of
data is optimal.
So now first we have the prior.
The prior tells us some theta values are
more likely than others.
We believe, for example,
these values are more likely than the
values like here or here or other
places.
So this is our prior.
And then we have our data likelihood.
In this case, the data also tells us
which values of theta are more likely
and that just means those theta values
can best explain our data.
And then when we combine the two, we
get the posterior distribution and
that's just a compromise of the two.
It would say that it's somewhere in
between, so we can now look at some
interesting point estimates of theta.
Now this point represents the mode of
prior.
That means the most likely parameter
value according to our prior before we
observe any data.
This point is the maximum likelihood
estimate that represents the theta that
gives the data the maximum probability.
Now this point is interesting.
It's the posterior mode, it's the.
It's the most likely value of theta
given by the posterior distribution,
and it represents a good compromise of
the prior mode and the maximum likehood
estimate.
In general, in Bayesian inference we
are interested in the distribution of
all these parameter values.
As you see, here is there's a
distribution over Theta values that you
can see here P of theta given X.
So the problem of Bayesian inference is
to infer this posterior distribution
and also to infer other interesting
quantities that might depend on Theta.
So I showed F of Theta here as an
interesting variable that we want to
compute.
But in order to compute this value, we
need to know the value of Theta.
In Bayesian inference, we treat data
as uncertain variable.
So we think about all the possible
values of Theta.
Therefore we can estimate the value of
this function F as the expected value
of F according to the posterior
distribution of data
given the observed evidence X.
As a special case, we can assume F
of Theta is just equal to Theta.
In this case we get the expected value
of Theta.
That's basically the posterior mean
that gives us also one point of Theta.
And
it's sometimes the same as posterior
mode, but it's not always the same, so
it gives us another way to estimate the
parameters.
So this is a general illustration of
Bayesian estimation and Bayesian inference.
inference.
And later you will see this can be
useful for topic mining where we want
to inject some prior knowledge about
the topics.
So to summarize, we introduced the
language model
which is basically probability
distribution over text.
It's also called a generative model for
text data.
The simplest language model is unigram
language model.
It's basically a word distribution.
We introduced the concept of likelihood
function which is the probability of
data given some model.
And this function is very important.
Given a particular set of parameter
values, this function can tell us which
X, which data point has a higher
likelihood, higher probability.
Given a data point, sorry, given a data
sample X, we can use this function to
determine which parameter values would
maximize the probability of the
observed data, and this is the maximum
likelihood estimate.
We also talked about the Bayesian
estimation or influence.
In this case we must define a prior on
the parameters P of Theta, and then
we're interested in computing the
posterior distribution of the
parameters which is
proportional to the prior and the
likelihood.
And this kind of
distribution would allow us, then, to
infer any derived values from Theta.